Alexander with fandango.com
thank you well hey tomorrow buy my
tickets to the movies well now you've
got two freebies Oh
oh my gosh friends are gonna die here
yeah yeah so have you had a chance to
enjoy yourself at all a comic-con or did
you just show up now um well well when
we were here for kick-ass I saw I kind
of experience I'm a little bit I guess I
mean we haven't been on the floor yet
but about soon we're going to the floor
soon which is it's pretty exciting yeah
I have it I want to say hi to Ryan
because I worked with Ryan Reynolds on
um on a medieval hard wine my first
feature film and then my gosh I had a
Mark Strong and I mean there's the world
of people he's still talking about the
beating he took from you he was funny
today we talked to him really yeah yes
he's a very nice guy so let's talk about
let me ever
how familiar were you with the story
before you signed on um I haven't I
hadn't seen leather I won't in yet
because I wanted to you know have my own
take on the character and my own take on
Abby and so what I did was on I just
kind of you know Jew off the script in
and got what I got from it and after the
film was over I did see parts of it but
my mom won't allow me to watch the whole
thing yet did your mom want to watch
kick-ass of course you know cuz that was
that was my film like OB you'll see this
one okay alright but if you know if it
wasn't my film definitely want it using
it definitely not
pg-13 just cuz I turned 13 really well
you seem much older I'm curious you know
there's there's been a lot of debate on
this either being a a remake or it's a
little or it's a little different
because it draws me all through the book
yeah I mean I definitely I wanted to
remake it's our own take on the book you
know it's our own take on Let The Right
One In and what I want to have seen of
the real you know let the right one in
the first take on the book it was a very
beautiful film in it it's really an
honor to have our take on after that
amazing amazing film let's talk a little
bit about your character for people that
that may not know about Let The Right
One In what's your character well Abby
is about 200 250 300 year old vampire
stuck she's an old soul stuck in a 12
year olds body and basically it's kind
of a trapped soul and she has this devil
inside of her that she can't really
control she wants to be a normal girl
but yet she's cursed with immortality
and to live forever and you befriend the
the olan like the kid next door I guess
right yes
now what kind of what kind of thrills
and is this more bloody or is this gonna
be more of a you know let that let your
mind kind of take over and cause the I
can't really say you know go see the
film all right all right give me some
then thank you